ah
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta edición especial
del debate de france 24 soy santiago
lópez gonzález en esta ocasión solo por
hoy el programa kobe 19 la semana en
américa se dio su espacio para poder
llevarles a ustedes este programa
especial con motivo del decimosexto
aniversario de la firma de los acuerdos
de evian dicho acuerdo buscaba poner fin
a la guerra entre argelia y francia un
conflicto que se extendió por casi 8
años y que cobró la vida de unas 300.000
personas pero también allanó el camino
para la independencia de argelia veamos
más detalles en el siguiente informe
elaborado por la redacción de france 24
se necesitaron meses de negociaciones
secretas previas y la aceleración de los
atentados en argel y parís a principios
de 1962 para que finalmente después de
ocho años de guerra cruenta las
conversaciones de piano se inaugurarán
oficialmente el 7 de marzo de 1962 entre
el gobierno francés y el ala política
del frente de liberación nacional la
conferencia duró 11 días tras las
conversaciones se estancaron
notablemente en dos temas el futuro de
la comunidad francesa residente en
argelia que finalmente no fue resuelto
por el acuerdo y la cuestión de la
soberanía del sahara parís exigió y
consiguió mantener durante varios años
el control de la región donde los
intereses petroleros y nucleares
franceses eran importantes
el 18 de marzo de 1962 se firmaron los
acuerdos de bien con un alto el fuego
que entró en vigor al mediodía del día
siguiente esa misma noche el general de
gaulle se dirigió a los franceses lo es
y su las disposiciones se adoptan para
que las poblaciones puedan disponer de
su destino y perspectiva del
procedimiento de un ángel independiente
cooperando estrechamente con nosotros
satisface la razón de formular eso
pedazos
en realidad la violencia continuarían
largos meses
lado a ese organización armada
clandestina formada por los partidos de
argelia francesa multiplicó los ataques
el fmln tomó represalias con asesinatos
y secuestros de europeos sospechosos de
estar cerca de la organización pero el
proceso de independencia previsto en los
acuerdos debía era inevitable en medio
de la atención el primero de julio de
1962 la población votó masivamente por
el sí a la independencia de argelia el
mismo día de una jornada sangrienta la
masacre de orán la inseguridad y la
violencia provocaron el éxodo hacia la
metrópoli de casi un millón de pie no a
pies negros personas de origen francés
que vivían en argelia en los barcos
había también unos 10.000 harkis
argelinos que hicieron parte del
ejército francés que permanecieron en
argelia y fueron a menudo víctimas de
represalias una dolorosa repatriación
cuyas heridas aún se sienten hoy en día
el alivio inicial que trajo el alto el
fuego logrado con estos acuerdos fue
efímero ya como lo veíamos el periodo de
transición fue particularmente violento
en ambos lados del mediterráneo la hoja
es este grupo paramilitar francés que
era disidente de la extrema derecha no
aceptó fácilmente la independencia de
argelia y por este motivo organizó un
gran número de ataques de bombardeos y
también asesinatos lo que llevó como
veíamos en el informe a un éxodo masivo
de ciudadanos no solamente franceses que
residían en el norte de áfrica sino
también a ciudadanos argelinos que
querían llegar a francia para tener unas
mejores condiciones de vida sin duda
alguna esto también modificó en cierta
manera a la sociedad francesa 60 años
después de la firma de estos acuerdos
que tanto ha sido implementado como es
la relación actual entre francia y
argelia francia ha conseguido superar su
pasado como potencia colonial represora
y argelia ha conseguido construir una
identidad aceptando precisamente su
pasado colonial como son hoy en día las
relaciones entre francia y también con
otros territorios del norte de áfrica
que fueron parte de sus posiciones en
este continente
hoy en el debate de france 24 analizamos
60 años después de la firma del acuerdo
de ivian y que él dio origen también al
fin de la guerra de independencia de
argelia y también el fin de las de los
conflictos entre francia y sus potencias
su potencia territorial allí en el
continente africano lo vamos a analizar
en el debate de france 24 y para
analizar este tema saludamos a llamar y
seno ls profesor de ciencia política y
estudios globales de la universidad de
los andes que está ubicada en la ciudad
de bogotá en colombia bienvenido y
también le doy la bienvenida a dago
comentan él es historiador africano
especializado en relaciones
internacionales en se encuentra en la
ciudad de las palmas en gran canaria en
españa' ustedes también pueden
participar en este debate a través de
sus comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales nos pueden encontrar en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
y arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral del debate
efe 24 comienzos entonces con llamar y
en la ciudad de bogotá dándole la
bienvenida a este programa especial de
france 24 y quiero comenzar como punto
de partida haciendo un balance de estos
60 años de la firma de este acuerdo de
esa de ese acuerdo que puso fin a la
guerra de independencia y que sentó las
bases de una relación de argelia y
francia como países como estados
independientes y comenzando a cerrar de
cierta forma esa historia colonial que
los une
sí muy buenas tardes y muchas gracias
por la invitación
santiago la cicatriz y abiertas 60 años
después de los acuerdos de enviar las
relaciones silenciando difíciles entre
argelia y francia y francia lo ha
superado del todo su pasado colonial y
lo vemos en las en la campaña
presidencial en las elecciones que
estamos viviendo en este momento d en
francia el tema de argelia el tema del
pasado colonial el tema también de las
personas que emigraron a francia después
provenientes de las diferentes colonias
de francia esos son temas que siguen muy
vigente en la actualidad entonces
podemos decir que si bien han pasado 60
años desde los acuerdos de enviar la
cicatriz y abierta y ahora le doy la
palabra a dago com en 'la en la ciudad
de las palmas en gran canaria también
bienvenido al programa ha dado su
opinión de estos 60 años que balance
puede hacer usted de 60 años desde la
firma de este acuerdo entre francia y
argelia
muchas gracias
con grasa permítanme en primer lugar
puedo decir
es hola esta conmemoración llega en un
momento de
campaña electoral así que todo está un
poco más tenso que lo normal pero
es lo que dijo
[Música]
y ha sido muy muy muy bien puesto porque
francia tiene aún mucho problema con su
pasado colonial no solo en argelia sino
cuando todo el continente africano así
que si las actividades de la
colonización francesa siguen abierta y
en la agilidad sobre todo por la
cantidad de muertos que hay que hubo en
el camino hacia la independencia pues se
vuelve aún más presente más o menos la
situación y puedo destacar de la
relación de francia ya sería llamar y a
lo largo de estos años se ha trabajado
de diferentes formas para lograr superar
esas dificultades que existieron entre
francia o que existen todavía entre
francia y argelia empezar a cerrar esas
heridas todavía muchas de ellas
permanecen abiertas se puede hablar de
una reconciliación entre ambos estados
entre ambos países con ese pasado
colonial en común y cuáles son esas
muestras de reconciliación
en si ha habido progresos ha habido
progresos por ejemplo desde
1999 francia reconoce la guerra de
independencia de argelia como como lo
que realmente fue una guerra hasta el 99
se hablaba en francia todavía de los
eventos de argelia no se usaba la
palabra guerra entonces ahí fue un
elemento clave para empezar ese proceso
de memoria es el proceso de
reconciliación y hemos visto en los
últimos años también los esfuerzos por
ejemplo en 2012 la creación de un día
para conmemorar en las víctimas civiles
de este conflicto y de también de
eventos que sucedieron en túnez y en
marruecos que es mañana el 10 y el 19 de
marzo era un día de esos acuerdos de
villar porque fue el día del cese al
fuego en argelia en el momento en el
cual las tropas francesas cesaron las
actividades digitales entonces ahí hay
como elementos que nos muestran que poco
a poco se va haciendo ese proceso de
memoria pero todavía es difícil y lo
vemos el año pasado se publicó un
informe por un historiador francés muy
muy famoso que se llama marianas tomas
que publicó justamente un informe acerca
de esas relaciones de francia y argelia
y no fue bien recibido por la derecha y
por la ultraderecha francesa entonces
todavía el tema sigue siendo un político
y hago en ustedes ciudadanos marfileños
reside ahora en españa y tal vez la
realidad de los países africanos que
pertenecieron a francia durante la época
colonial y tienen algunos puntos en
común por ese pasado por haber sido
controlados desde parís desde américa
latina' de la realidad africana es muy
distante es muy poco conocido como fue
este pasado colonial y cómo fueron las
luchas de independencia de cada uno de
estos estados francófonos o que
pertenecieron a francia en algún momento
y
creo que sería oportuno que usted nos
explicará porque si bien américa latina'
también tiene un pasado colonial es muy
distinto al pasado que ustedes han
tenido ustedes fueron parte de francia
hasta el siglo 20 cuáles son esos
reclamos que todavía tienen los
diferentes países del norte de áfrica y
áfrica occidental a francia como antigua
colonia y antiguo poder colonial en
áfrica
bueno en primer lugar
hay una diferencia sustancial
estructural entre la colonización que
aunque se dio en argelia y la que hubo
en los países al sur del sahara templo
argelia fue primero una colonia de
poblamiento mientras que las demás
colonia fueron de explotación como
nosotros hemos solemos hacer la
distinción allí no hubo un proceso de
integración a la metrópolis como había
en la gélida energía había un tiempo en
francia había un dicho
al final es decir 19 sí que decía que el
mediterráneo cruza francia como el río
sena cruza parís así que no era lo mismo
cuando se trataba de agelia y de los
países subsaharianos
y la segunda diferencia es que el ágil
ya obtuvo la independencia mediante una
guerra una guerra de
autodeterminación mientras que nosotros
tuvimos un proceso de independencia
mucho más fácil pero aún así
a nosotros la principal queja que sé que
hay es que hay una intromisión muy
fuerte de francia en los asuntos los
países lo que se suele llamar la front
sea free que mientras que en ágil ya es
un
historial memorial muy distinta que está
basada en eso de la sangre que hay entre
ambos países y sobre todo el contexto
también hay que contextualizar el
contexto del apoyo francés a marruecos
desde la perspectiva argelina también
juega en este en esta
como decía en esa relación de francia y
argelia y eso impide un poco nada que se
ponga una relación muy muy
y más pacífica o más tranquila entre
ambos países y así producir las
diferencias entre los dos y jean-marie
algo para complementar sobre este tema
sobre esa relación entre francia y sus
antiguas colonias africanas y le añado a
esa pregunta porque la relación en
particular con argelia ha sido tan
tirante y tan tensa a lo largo de la
historia a diferencia de otros
territorios allí en áfrica
en si la relación ha sido un fuerte con
todas las colonias y sigue habiendo
digamos demandas y reclamos por parte de
las antiguas colonias como lo mencionó
dragón pero en el caso de artea ya
estamos en una situación un poco
distinta en la cual muchos franceses
vivían en argelia no había una relación
eran departamentos franceses no eran
colonias y los departamentos parte del
país como tal
y todos los franceses tienen algún tipo
de relación tengo una prima que nació en
argelia aps en mi vecino
fue soldado durante la guerra de argelia
o sea digamos que cuando vida en francia
este pasado colonial era muy presente en
el caso de argelia y tal vez un poquito
más lejano un poquito más también en los
asuntos económicos en relación con las
otras colonias
y porque este relacionamiento es
distinto si uno lo compara con otros
procesos de descolonización en áfrica al
caso del reino unido- cuando empezó a
dejar libres algunos de sus territorios
allí en el continente africano también
el caso de portugal que es un poco más o
menos simultáneo el proceso que se da en
áfrica en la década de los 60 es del
siglo 20 porque el proceso con francia
es distinto porque el relacionamiento es
diferente en este sentido hago la
pregunta porque como lo dije hace unos
momentos es una realidad muy alejada
américa latina' que no entendemos bien
cómo es este relacionamiento entre
europa y los territorios africanos
porque la relación que tenemos en
américa latina' o por lo menos los que
fuimos colonia española es muy distinta
a la relación que tenemos con madrid y
llama mucho la atención hay una buena
sintonía por ejemplo entre lisboa luanda
y maputo cosa que no se ve mucho en el
relacionamiento francés le hago la
pregunta a llamar y hago la ronda a la
inversa
y bueno pues ahí creo que el historiador
será más en capacidad de contestar este
punto en particular pero es cierto que
el proceso de descolonización francés
fue más violento que el proceso de
descolonización por ejemplo de reino
unido en el caso de argelia como decía
es distinto por por el poblamiento en
estamos ser una relación un poco como
mencionaba en el caso de américa latina
y la relación con españa pues la guerra
de independencia en colombia de nosotros
países latinoamericanos fue muy dura fue
muy violenta fue muy larga porque había
un sentimiento de pertenencia que va
mucho más allá de digamos la colonia
tradicional donde se extraen algunos
recursos naturales donde se mandan a tal
vez a hacer como la producción de
algunos productos en este caso era
poblamiento de la parte de la identidad
tanto de los departamentos franceses de
argelia como de la de la metrópoli de
francia entonces de esa relación fue
mucho más difícil de
soltar y por eso podemos ver todas
pues lo que hago mencionaba de france
áfrica y la la la la intervención o la
intromisión de francia en los asuntos
africanos y también en el caso de
argelia una una relación que sigue
siendo difícil a nivel identitario y
cultural
a lo largo del periodo presidencial del
presidente macrón algunos analistas han
dicho que ha habido unas muestras por
parte de parís para
acercar un poco más a las partes pero
desde argel y estos son algunos algunas
acusaciones que hacen en parís no ha
habido muchas muestras tal vez por la
transición política que están viviendo
en argelia en este momento para ver un
poco de reciprocidad por parte de
argelia hacia francia en cuanto a los
hechos que sucedieron a lo largo de la
guerra de independencia porque como
murieron argelinos también murieron
muchísimos franceses y muchísimos
soldados franceses los reclamos van y
vienen en ambas direcciones en el
mediterráneo' esta argel simplemente
haciéndose la de la vista gorda y
esperando que francia de más muestras y
de más respuestas o como lo analiza
usted
bueno pienso que el cambio político que
buena ella con el girar y tan bueno el
cambio político y también la gira que
hace que el poder ágil y no es un poco
un más débil así que ésta intenta
incentivar el sentimiento nacionalista
para tener algo de credibilidad a nivel
en interior y como lo decía
recientemente
la relación con marruecos también juega
mucho porque desde desde argel se ve que
francia mucho más
permisivo con marruecos y argelia que
tiene una relación muy
[Música]
y no llegaremos al punto de decir
conflictual pero la relación difícil con
consumir sido sobre todo en el caso del
sahara occidental web
/ intentado cómo
mantenerse mantener él
el enemigo frase perdón con la expresión
para para poder mantener este
nacionalismo eso también pero hay que
tener en cuenta que muchos argelinos han
han ido a francia y han ido a trabajar a
estudiar
a vivir a francia así que más bien
pienso que hay un proceso de
instrumentalización de la historia que
te permite incentivar como decía este
sentimiento nacional
quiero profundizar en ese tema se habla
de este sentimiento nacionalista se
habla de este discurso que puede ser
utilizado por los políticos en ciertos
escenarios para fomentar este
sentimiento nacionalista que tanto haya
cada discurso político y de percepción
de los ciudadanos es decir hagamos ahí
la diferencia entre lo que piensan las
autoridades argelinas y lo que puede
pensar un ciudadano argelino del común
de verdad existe este sentimiento de
tanta y recelo hacia francia de tanto
resentimiento o los argelinos
simplemente viven su día a día
tranquilos llevan sobre su espalda la
historia que pesa de su país pero viven
pensando en el presidente mientras que
los políticos usan el pasado para
poderse mantener en el presente
exactamente
y es que estaba viendo un reportaje de
una cadena francesa
sobre esto que daba la palabra a los
angelinos y daba su opinión sobre los
sucesos y muchos de ellos asumían este
pasado pero el pasado ya se ha ocurrido
no se puede cambiar el pasado es como
bueno ya pasó tenemos que seguir
adelante pero también no
hay que hay que tener en cuenta que
francia también a veces sigue la
corriente a estos políticos ágil y no
por ejemplo cuando ágil ya ganó
la copa de fútbol africana pues hubo
quejas de que los angelinos viviendo en
francia salgan a la calle
para celebrarlo con la bandera
agilidades
también esos elementos
son son fallos en el que los extremistas
de ambos bandos pues permitan que sigan
estos
la relación digamos tóxica
y joan marí y ahora le hago esta
pregunta pero desde el otro lado del
mediterráneo en el lado francés que
tanto estas discrepancias entre parís y
argel le sirve para el discurso a los
políticos hoy en día estamos como usted
lo mencionaba en un momento de campaña
electoral y son aspectos que que pueden
entrar allí a jugar siempre lo que
sucede en argelia es noticia en los
diarios franceses hay todavía una
conexión muy estrecha además está poco
más de dos horas cruzando el
mediterráneo dos horas de vuelo desde
parís un poco más es un territorio que
está muy cercano como lo utilizan los
políticos franceses esta historia las
discrepancias que hay e intentar cerrar
estas heridas esta difícil
reconciliación entre las partes
sí pues es uno de los puntos como lo
mencionaba de la campaña presidencial
pero también es parte del discurso de la
extrema derecha en francia desde el
momento de la independencia desde los
primeros grupos terroristas que seguían
reivindicando una presencia del francés
en argelia entonces
la derecha la otra la derecha francesa
se creó y creció y se desarrolló con
base en esta narrativa del tema de
argelia y del problema de identidad que
existe con con argelia entonces cada vez
que como lo mencionó hago cada vez que
hay una victoria de fútbol de los
argelinos y que está acá en una bandera
en las calles de materias o de parís es
polémico a nivel a nivel político y la
ultraderecha va a retomar ese ejemplo
ese caso aislado para tratar de
desarrollar esa narrativa de un choque
cultural entre musulmanes y franceses no
musulmanes entonces es como parte del
discurso de la ultraderecha y se
menciona en este momento por ejemplo en
el presente macro no va a participar en
la conmemoración mañana pero la extrema
derecha dice que no se debería celebrar
no sería anti conmemorar ese día porque
la violencia siguió después de esas
fechas y como lo vimos también en las
imágenes al principio de este programa
en estas violencias también aceptaron a
ciudadanos franceses que vivían en
argelia entonces como parte de la
recuperación de esos eventos por la
ultraderecha francesa explica por qué es
el tema de argelia sigue siendo tan
vigente y 60 años después de la
independencia un tema vigente 60 años
después y en ese orden de ideas llamar y
como cambio la sociedad francesa la
composición y la forma de verse a sí
misma la sociedad francesa después de la
firma de estos acuerdos después de haber
ser retirado de los territorios
africanos y haberse replegado digámoslo
así solamente en el territorio europeo
como cambiaron los franceses después de
esto
la sociedad francesa cambió mucho y
todavía hay un debate acerca de la nueva
identidad de francia y eso es un debate
que no está resuelto todavía el
presidente macro desde el primer
presidente que nació después de la
guerra de argelia después de la
independencia de argelia entonces es
algo kissinger pasó hace 60 años sigue
siendo muy presente y hoy en día tenemos
una sociedad francesa que es en gran
parte del resultado de la historia
francesa y también de la historia
colonial del franz entonces hay
descendientes de argelinos descendientes
de áfrica descendientes de colonias de
asia que vinieron a francia y que se
instalaron y tenemos hoy en día mucha
gente que tiene esa identidad múltiple
de ser franceses pero de tener como una
herencia de estas antiguas colonias
francesas y es sobre el tema del debate
identitario de las últimas campañas
presidenciales y que a veces debe
digamos instrumentalizado por la derecha
y la ultraderecha
y hago 60 años desde la firma de estos
acuerdos prácticamente 60 años de la
independencia de argelia este país como
se ha construido a sí mismo como ha
construido la identidad como nación a
partir de ahí es un país africano es un
país árabe es un país magrebí es un país
francófono pero también le da espacio a
las lenguas locales le hago la pregunta
sabiendo que usted es marfileño no es
argelino pero que usted en su país puede
haber dividido tal vez un poco esa misma
transición ver cómo se ha construido la
identidad de estos estados africanos en
estas seis décadas
bueno
después de independencia de argelia
el país se sintió muy africano organizó
por ejemplo una cumbre del
panafricanismo pero después se replegó
sobre el mundo árabe y ahí sí es que se
empezó un distanciamiento con los países
de áfrica subsahariana digamos y pienso
que es
en los 90 con la crisis de la guerra
civil el levantamiento actuales de los
90 que ángel ya volvió a jugar un papel
en azúcar subsahariana y en 2015 otra
vez en el acuario de ángel permitió para
poner fin a la luz a las posibilidades
en el conflicto valència
entonces pienso que al principio aquel
ya intentó abrirse hacia el continente
africano pero poco a poco sobre todo con
la guerra civil que conoció el país y
todo hubo como en el país y si rompo con
el mundo y después de ésta ésta está
intentando volver en la escena
internacional y sobre todo porque su
aliado tradicional
normalmente había desaparecido eso es un
formaciones y también que hay que
subrayar su aliado tradicional que era
la uls había desaparecido así que ahora
mismo está intentando volver
a tener peso pero ya sé si sirve un poco
superado por su rival digamos rival
natural que marruecos y tiene mucho más
influencia a nivel continental y argelia
así que para concluir diría que ágil ya
pues intenta pero está
ahora más bien cerrado en sí mismo que
hacia el continente claro es que quiere
decir que están viendo una transición
política importante ha finalizado un
gobierno después de muchísimos años de
tener a buteflika de presidente y están
en una transición prima en los asuntos
internos por encima de los asuntos
internacionales no es algo un poco del
contexto de la firma de estos acuerdos y
esa independencia de argelia el jean
marie para preguntarle un poco del tema
de la coyuntura internacional en este
momento y es que argelia ha vuelto a
quedar de nuevo
las portadas de los medios
internacionales y en las mesas de debate
a nivel internacional por la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania precisamente por
el suministro de gas varios países
europeos de han pedido a argelia que
vuelva a poner en funcionamiento el
gasoducto magreb españa a través del
territorio de marruecos para llevar gas
de argelia a europa y así empezar a
depender menos del gas
ruso ya lago no se explicaba la estrecha
relación que tiene argelia y moscú
precisamente argelia no quiere empezar a
fastidiar un poco en el kremlin pero
podría esto llevar a un acercamiento
entre francia o la unión europea con
argelia precisamente por esta necesidad
de suministros de hidrocarburos
yo creo que ahí la unión europea puede
jugar un papel porque hay muchos países
estados miembros de la unión europea que
tienen no tiene en este pasado colonial
con argelia que no tienen digamos esas
heridas abiertas de las cuales estábamos
hablando y entonces hay más allá de la
relación bilateral entre francia y
argelia hay un potencial de cooperación
entre reunión europea y argelia sobre
todo en el contexto que usted menciona
la falta de suministro de gas para los
países europeos por la guerra y la
invasión de ucrania por parte de rusia
entonces ahí argelia tiene algo que
ofrecer muy importante pero de nuevo
volvemos a este tema que mencionaba
también algo de la difícil relación con
marruecos y la cuestión del sáhara
occidental que sigue siendo un tema
entre los dos estados entonces este
gasoducto pasa por marruecos para llegar
a españa para llegar a la unión europea
y ahí hay una cooperación que debe
existir a nivel mediterráneo entre la
unión europea y esos países del magreb y
no únicamente y lateralmente o
únicamente con argel y rápidamente
llamaría argelia le cuesta mucho liderar
en el mediterráneo marruecos es el país
que lidera o lidera un poco más
egipto que está un poco más al este del
mediterráneo allí quien quien pone un
poco más las las marchas en el
mediterráneo en el norte de áfrica
pues ahí hay agendas muy distintas entre
los diferentes de estados y y eso fue
mencionado también argelia ti no ha
tenido una una situación interna muy
difícil desde la guerra civil en los
años 90 la transición política que está
viviendo las demandas en términos
económicos y de oportunidades políticas
de la juventud en argelia entonces ahí
hay muchas dificultades internas que
impiden realmente ese papel de liderazgo
marruecos no tiene más egipto digamos
que pertenece a otra esfera cultural y
no directamente
no dentro de la competencia directa con
con argelia porque estamos hablando de
países occidentales que
digamos tienen una proximidad geográfica
directa con países como españa
o incluso fans
me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa dago quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que deja
la firma de este acuerdo aspectos
positivos o negativos como usted lo
quiera resaltar en su conclusión y lo
que puede venir a futuro para esa
relación entre estos dos países hablo de
france argelia
bueno pienso que él los acuerdos de
indian primero fueron fueron un gran
paso adelante en la relación de francia
y argelia
porque pronto metió en un alto el fuego
y también con respecto a la relación de
futuro pienso que mucho va a depender de
la relación sobre todo entre marruecos y
argelia sobre todo en como decía es en
un d del gasoducto porque allí sí que es
el problema de problema no es el
suministro de gas y pienso que agelia
ganaría en suministrar el gas y ya que
ahora mismo están en europa están
buscando la alternativa pero claro la
gente más huecos y van están como el
obstáculo que impiden me pide una
cooperación muy extensa así que para
terminar pienso que esta relación la
unión europea puede
facilitar común
un asentamiento de unas buenas
relaciones entre marruecos y argelia y
eso ayudaría tanto a la unión europea
una de agelia
y llamar y su conclusión para el cierre
del programa
pues si estos acuerdos serán
indispensables esta independencia era
algo que se tenía que dar pero vemos que
el proceso de memoria de reconciliación
y
llevamos su tiempo llevamos más tiempo y
está muy atrasado pero todavía no es no
es tarde hay posibilidades de empezar
este contexto de reconciliación porque
está en cooperación a futuro es muy
importante llamar y dago les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros en el
programa habernos explicado esta
realidad tan lejana tan ajena para
américa latina pero sumamente
interesante para entender ese
relacionamiento entre francia y las ex
colonias africanas a ustedes muchísimas
gracias por la sintonía y pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios en las redes
sociales
[Música]